I'm at a party I'm taking just a couple
minutes out to tell you that gold has an
e number a numbers of the numbers given
by the European Food Safety Group or
whatever and gold is technically a food
additive you can have it for a
decoration or you know in little drinks
or something like that and you can also
get it in this form you can get this
gold leaf and this is well for gold it's
quite cheap each sheet cost about a
pound less than a micron it's been
rolled and rolled and rolled wrong wrong
flattened and put into this little
booklet and well that means you can do
all sorts of things with it but one
thing you can do is with a bit of luck
you can that we really Carol here
because just get close shop of that and
so with a bit of luck I should be able
hello hi
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
and happy oh that does not taste good
I'm guessing since you asked that he's
pretty much gonna go unaltered through
me